good morning believe nation today's
message is have hope over to you Barack
Obama that's what hope is imagining and
then fighting for and then working for
what did not seem possible before that's
leadership John F Kennedy didn't look up
at the moon and say oh that's too far we
can go false hopes Martin Luther King
and stand on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial and say go home everybody the
dreams deferred false hopes you all need
a reality check there is a moment in the
life of every generation when that
spirit of hopefulness has to come
through if we are to make our mark on
history so what do you think wow yeah
you gotta have hope
you gotta otherwise you'll give up right
it's not preneur you and in general in
life you gotta have hope for the future
and sometimes hope sucks cuz it feels
like it's a long time off but you gotta
have it you gotta keep believing in
yourself and what else could I say yeah
I mean hope is super tied to believe
I think being an entrepreneur is so hard
and there's so many it's not the
practical thing to do it's almost never
the smart thing to do it's the thing
that makes you come alive and you have
to have hope and believe that somehow
it's all gonna work out that by doing
something that you love that is
hopefully adding value to people's lives
that even if you don't know how the path
is gonna form for you and you just see
darkness everywhere around and you have
those dark moments you feel like it's
not going to work out we all have them
we all want to quit you know we all want
to cry but our business have the hope
that it will work out and the thing that
really helped me through this was one
knowing that I'm doing something
important and that is helping people
even if it's only helping three people
yeah at the beginning it's helping
somebody and so I know if it helps three
people I have the ability to help
thousands of people and then also
studying successful people and learning
their stories in understanding that
everybody failed everybody thought about
quitting everybody had these issues that
you're not so different and the key
thing that helped entrepreneurs get
through wasn't how smart they were their
family background or their education it
was they persevered they kept going they
continued to have hope and eventually
made it and you can too so question of
the day today is
do you have a time when hope helps you
out
oh I like it though question yeah that
that could get deep and meaningful okay
all right
when did hope help you out leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join in
discussion oh oh it's turning red it's
turning around we got to run thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot